bro speaking of uh
speaking of wild wild places in
the middle of nowhere california yeah i
so you know i went to kelly slater surf
branch on yeah thursday right yeah and
talk about that after it's one of the
best days of my life
by far um but the night before it was in
lamore california
sort of by fresno three hours and 15
minutes away
but with traffic on the 405 i left
during rush hour like nice
idiot so it took you half a day took me
four it took me four and a half hours to
get to the turn off
to go from the five to the highway that
it takes you to go to lamore
nice and i missed it and so i had to
drive halfway up the five and then take
this like
just sketchy ass highway
completely like potholes every five
seconds the drive was like this for 45
minutes
pitch black nobody on the [ __ ] road
nobody
right so i'm in i'm like i'm in the
middle of nowhere like where is this
place
there's like a house deep in the
distance like a farmhouse
and like another one deep i saw like
three people total driving on that road
i was like we have to be like just
completely in the middle of the desert
right
i'm staying at this hotel that's near
the surf ranch it's called the
cause it's a casino hotel yeah nice
website it's like casino
whatever and i'm like okay cool maybe i
can get a couple hands of blackjack in
before i wake up and go to the surf
ranch right
like the night before like maybe have a
beer sit at the tables whatever
i walk in there must have been like
6 000 people there
like and everyone on the slot machine is
just putting their [ __ ]
clan yeah putting their stimulus check
directly into the slot machines
sitting there everyone's ripping
cigarettes smoking inside which i'm not
you know in california you don't see
that no no
it was wild how do they have that
[ __ ] crazy i don't i think it's like
a native american reserve
oh okay like similar to the like the one
on the way to palm springs i think it's
the same thing right
oh yeah i'm not exactly sure yeah yeah
yeah it was crazy
nice it was really wild like everyone
inside barely wearing
masks all playing slot machines yeah
they cut a hole in to put the cigarette
in
yeah yeah exactly as long as they fill
it with a cigarette
the corona can't get in
nice so yeah how's the surf was it like
i was unreal man
it's a scene crazy i've i haven't felt
like that in
so long where like like since i was
little probably like
yeah with the gates open i was giddy i
was like i couldn't stop laughing
i was like a small child i was like dude
what the [ __ ] is this so
sick they were like yeah here's four
super 73
motorbikes so you can just take out and
rip around the i guess what it used to
be is like a wake boarding lake
it was built there like a while ago to
practice wakeboarding and they knew it
was there so they bought it and then
built the surf
uh the surf part beside it so you can
still rip around the
lake there's like gourmet food there
they serve like you walk in right away
you get like banana bread
egg sandwich and it's all like delicious
and then every time you get out of the
water from a session
a girl walks up to you with coconut
water and water
and there's snacks like constantly dang
it's
unreal it's like disneyland for servers
that's crazy i i just i had like the
best [ __ ] day ever it was
nuts it was the best wave i've ever
surfed the best i have ever surfed in
general
just because i the waves are so long you
like legitimately get better you know
yeah can like is it the type of thing
where it's like
you can just pay to go or do you have to
get invited like
how does it work you rent it out got it
i think the only way you can really go
is if you get like invited for some
brand thing
or if people rent it out like it's
booked i think like they said like 250
days out of the year
whoa and it's it's like it's now it's
50k
and that's when you get a deal to book
it out for the day
people pay 100k to surf there for one
day
i mean running that thing doesn't seem
cheap
yeah i don't know i it must cost so much
like so much power to run that thing
yeah pumping that water like that it has
to be something crazy
yeah that's insane dude congrats you you
avoided a 50k
tab i know and you can say you did it
that's sick
i mean all thanks to casey i appreciate
you
nice yeah he he hooked it up
and i met some great people too yeah i
was gonna say pro surfers there yeah
were there any pros
that's it yeah super dope surfing with
them i mean it's like inspiring you know
like i watched kalani rob i was on the
road i was in the water with
kalani rob yeah and he's like one of the
most famous surfers he's like one of
kelly's boys from
you know the north shore and uh
he came in the water we did a night
session and he came in the water with a
light up pink board it had leds on it
and he wore a bright pink wetsuit
and i was like third down the water or
whatever so by the time he got to me on
the wave he was tucked in the barrel
at night and i was in the water and i
like went up the face of the wave and
just we made eye contact him in
the barrel like tucked slotted in there
with a bright pink board at night it was
[ __ ] crazy
i was like that's one of the most
beautiful things i've ever seen my
entire life dude needs a 360 gopro on
the front of his board that sounds
insane
it was sick shot so cool
i'm just picturing the lights like
bouncing off the inside of that as well
oh yeah you gotta you know take a little
uh little pop a little fun pill you know
pop a little bean before you do
something like that maybe he was on
molly you know
yeah rolling his balls off oh
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] these lights dude
this way maybe i should have been you
know this water feels so good in your
hands
just one with it bro yeah
it was pretty funny it was like the
first session i did was awesome
because it's like my first time surfing
the wave it was just like i was high
afterwards and in the second session
i was a little bit used to it so i got
in the water and i knew what i wanted to
accomplish
and i wasn't like in the right places i
couldn't really poach a lot of waves and
then people were taking waves in front
of me that
weren't you know the line was switching
around or whatever and then finally the
guy came to me and he's like hey man
because you each you get two priority
waves each person in that
heat so it's like yeah two two waves
where you're the person that starts on
it you can take the whole thing if you
want
got it and so he came over and he was
like hey man
uh we got to get you on this left sorry
it's like one of the only waves left and
i was like
because i hate going left i'm such a
suck it's backside right you're on your
heel it's like
yeah i just suck at it i look like an
idiot
poop stance you know so i'm like oh man
you don't have a right for me and he was
like all right fine we'll just run an
empty one then and i was like
ah and at that moment i was like wait
i'm like one of the luckiest people on
the planet
right now that gets to surf this way
like of course i'll surf the best left
in the entire world
so i was like i apologize i i would
gladly take the left
it's just all right man cool run a
[ __ ] empty one then cool you know i'm
sure no one was gonna be pissed if we
run an empty wave
let's go run it
this [ __ ] guy yes [ __ ] guy
i guess we'll just run all the lefts
empty huh cody
no no no no i can go left what kind of
supper are you
everybody stay off the left cody doesn't
like the left no one has to surf the
lefts okay
just mad rude
i know i was just it was just a question
i didn't really realize what i was
saying oh yeah no no no no no yeah we'll
do it your way
dude for sure
uh yeah so anyways that's i really
there's nothing really funny happened it
just was
i just can't express enough like how
incredible it was
yeah no it seems it seemed like really i
because i i only know
how exclusive that is like some like i
don't know vice equivalent
documentary from way back when he was
building it i remember the sound of it
thinking or you know what they described
i'm like damn that's
insane to just build a wave machine
i was so nervous for the first one yeah
because i guess it's pretty common for
you to miss your first one
yeah cause you're in a pool that's like
a giant rectangle
but the wave is at a 45 degree angle it
comes out from the wall like this
oh weird so when you're paddling people
like want to be
parallel to the wall yeah because that
feels natural but you actually have to
be straight onto the wave so you have to
paddle 45 degree angle
weird and i guess that really [ __ ] with
people and so they'll miss the first
wave and it's like
250 bucks per wave or something like
that or more 2 500 bucks per wave or
something like it breaks down to that
because it's so expensive to run that
thing
and to rent the park so if you miss it
you just feel like a giant dick
yeah a waste of money yeah yeah so
anyways anyways
yeah i guess we'll run an empty wave
then yeah yeah
cool no he doesn't want to go left guys
no no no no he's the king
yeah well i'm sorry you're you're last
night you're kelly slater
right or your son or what oh you're just
doing
something i can't serve okay yeah slater
jr here doesn't want to go left so
what's your name bro no slater in there
i see
okay yeah no no it's cool it's cool no
we'll run an empty left is fine
yeah write a check for 2500 bucks and we
can run an empty left
he just pulls out a waterproof square
reader no no empty left is cool man just
go ahead
and run it insert your chip right here
insert the chip right there yeah you can
just tap it if you want
yeah feel free to tip man feel free to
don't forget
because i'm the one who has to go up and
tell the guy to run an empty wave so you
know
because clearly you didn't want to do
that so you tell me
it's cool man
yeah that feeling about being giddy i i
relate to that
the most when i when i last time i went
driving carts i had like a couple laps
where i actually felt like i figured it
out it was kind of the same thing i was
like
giggling the whole time i was driving oh
yeah
just you really know i mean this is the
most surface thing to say in the world
but you really know what it means to be
stoked or like psyched or whatever
like it's that it's that high it's like
more than runners high more than
it's like you get out of the water you
get out of the cart and you're like i
improved at something like as an old
person
you know as a 30 year old it's really
tough to have those like weird
measures of improvement you know yeah no
i agree
i agree [ __ ] we didn't talk about white
boy summer
oh all right we'll talk about it in the
bone zone
we'll talk about some bones what do you
say what's my favorite thing that
happened this week
between love chet hanks between chet
ben and jake it's
starting to stack up like a white boy
pre-summer that's for sure
oh my boy spring white boy spring free
summer
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] spring dude just
pre-summer white boy pre-summer
white boy pre-summer yeah
yeah man yeah i mean here's the thing
though i'm kind of like not the type of
white boy he's talking about you know
yeah yeah you're not included actually
he was like he said that i was like yeah
white boy summer let's go and then he's
like
and then he's like snapbacks or
no get that [ __ ] out of here and then
like you know a lot of the things that
he said
you know i don't know i'm not rocking
sperries but you were slowly kind of
disrobing
you're like oh no definitely not yeah
flannel shirts yeah
[ __ ] get rid of that [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's not really number at all
yeah salmon wait salmon shirts
yes
yeah it's not white boy summer for you
if you've ever owned a salmon
mint or
bet um uh damn it
like fisherman's blue uh button-up
t-shirt
yeah yeah my favorite part of the whole
spiel was when he was like and
no more using the term smoke show it's
played out
bro like that's so funny that's so
like i mean he's he's actually a really
funny guy
yeah like you can tell he knows what the
[ __ ] he's doing but he's also
unintentionally really funny too
yeah like that's such a funny thing
because like
smoke show no one really says that
anymore and it's not that fatty
like every dude says that sort of but
it's like a weird old term
that's like just to bar that is so funny
like no more saying smoke show
there was a smoke show don't do it
i was listening to the future the other
day and he referred to a girl in his
song as a smoker and i was like he's
going to take this up with chet
that's not very white boy summer i mean
no it's like
chet is saying smoke show is for white
guys
and don't say was he saying all guys or
just white guys
i think it was white guys i think his
whole thing is like white boys we have
to evolve
so stop doing these things god because
it's white boy summer and in order for
it to be white boy summer
we gotta elevate so you got to stop
saying smoke show
yeah no more saying smoke show maybe you
can still say smoke
just smoke because the abbreviated form
like she's a smoke yeah
that's a smoker smoker that's good
future said he was like she's a smoker
i was like chet
future says it i mean but granted you
know
future's definitely not in um the white
boy category so
yeah so we can we can rip the videos in
the bonus how about that
should we yeah yeah man we should play
we should play the
cameo before we ride out that cameo
yes yes the one with the bowing down or
whatever taking it
what did he say he's like that's me
bowing to you just play it get my black
just play it oh
oh man is it crazy
do we have the clip clip clip
do we have the clip
oh yeah i want that one that one yeah
this is it
let that rip
alexis what's up baby it's chicken hanks
this girl baby amber schiffer that's a
strong name
um she told me that you're a black queen
that's me taking a bow to the queen um
or you're playing in my white boy summer
thing i got going on
i appreciate that um and that you hate
sperry's as well
but you love vans me and you would
definitely get along if you ever see me
come holla at me bye alexa
love that i love that we would
definitely get along
definitely get along here you're a fan
of the whole white boy summer thing i
got going on
he was like he did one he did one
instagram story and he was like it was
the day after the white
he did the white boy summer video the
first one and it kind of went viral and
he's like tim
woke up today internet gone mad again
internet gone mad stop
it the part that kills me about this
cameo is like
heard you hate spares you like vans it's
like that sounds like a 16 year old bro
it's like the idea of a teenager
receiving this cameo and he's just like
putting on this whole act like alexis
yeah this whole white boy's summer thing
i got going on
yeah i'm sure we get along great
oh my god caller at me he said
holler at me
all right
you